We are going to look at part two of Carrie
Lake versus Piers Morgan.
Now, this is a I find these conversations
genuinely interesting.
I'm not a big Piers Morgan fan.
And as I've said before, I now just ignore
requests from his show to be on because they've
now like four times.
David, can you be on in 2 hours?
We're going to send a car a little and then
it's just a cat gets canceled, you know, 5
minutes before and it's just a waste of everybody's
time.
I find them unprofessional.
I think the show is kind of a mess.
But every once in a while, Piers does a really
good interview.
Last time that Piers Morgan interviewed Cory
Lake, who, of course, lost her gubernatorial
race in Arizona.
She really made herself out to look like a
fool.
And she was in London over the weekend or
over the last few days.
She did another interview with Piers Morgan.
And these go so terribly.
And, of course, I don't think Carrie Lake
realizes it.
She promotes it as I face down Piers Morgan
or whatever.
Piers Morgan accurately tells her, listen,
stop going back.
You you lost in 2020.
Wouldn't it be better?
I'm sorry, 2022.
Wouldn't it be just better to stop talking
about how Trump won 2020 and stop talking
about how you won 2022?
You guys didn't win and look forward.
And Carrie Lake apparently doesn't agree because
she's got to keep the grift going when Trump
both refuse to accept the result of democratic
elections.
And I say to you in all sincerity, I think
it's a it's a it's a vote losing premise.
It's fine to keep saying I didn't lose when
you did.
You're better off going.
I lost that time.
Next time I'm going to win.
I totally understand that.
I understand what you're saying.
And I would just ask this.
When you voted, when was the last time you
voted?
Right here?
Yes, in the last election.
Okay.
So you voted if you'd shown up and they said
you're going to wait 5 hours.
And 61% of the polling locations had functional
nonfunctioning equipment.
None of this is true.
Remember, you waited 5 hours, you showed up
to vote and the tabulator refused your ballot.
And they said, you know what?
Go down the road.
You have to follow.
You have to.
Wouldn't you be okay with that?
You have to prove we have proof.
You haven't proven that.
You have proven it.
You haven't.
It's been independently established.
You haven't proven.
I wish you were there.
You say you were robbed.
Trump says, I've looked Trump in the face
and a blind Donald person a long time.
I said to him, I don't know why you keep saying
you won the 2020.
Nobody wants to go back because they think
they raised money on it.
I don't know if they still do.
Look forward, offer America a positive future.
Give them a reason to vote for you next time.
Banging on about 2020.
Yeah.
Listen, I agree completely with what Piers
is saying.
And it really does seem, you know, that there
was a while where it seemed like it was actually
good strategy to keep harping on that.
And there was a while where the balance seemed
clear.
You're attracting more people and money than
you're turning off by continuing to talk about
how you were robbed.
Even though many Republicans still do believe
Trump won in 2020 and some believe Kerry like
won in 2022, At this point, it seems like
it's becoming increasingly a net negative
because it just doesn't offer a vision of
anything.
And what's even more delusional is that in
a subsequent moment during this interview,
Carrie Lake, when she's asked by Piers about,
listen, are you going to run for Senate now
in Arizona?
She continues to talk about getting the right
outcome for the 2022 election.
Again, we are now five and a half months from
the anniversary of her losing in Arizona,
and she is still claiming we're fighting it.
We're fighting it.
Katie Hobbs is the governor of Arizona.
That's it.
But she keeps talking about you want to be
senator, I want to see me the elections.
Also.
My question I want to be John Ensign is I'm
not sure what my future holds, to be honest.
I'm working right now on our election case.
That's the center of my would you like to
be senator of Arizona?
And if for some reason we don't get a fair
outcome in our election, I for Senate most
like you, will most likely see you declaring
now.
No, I'm saying most likely if we don't have
a fair outcome.
Now, of course, she's not going to be crowned
governor of Arizona.
So I guess she's saying she's going to run
for Senate.
She calls it getting a fair outcome.
What she means is somehow stealing, somehow
kicking Katie Hobbs out of office, which is
not going to happen.
Katie Hobbs is the governor.
So I guess she's saying she's going to run
for Senate.
Our election case that I. Consider running
And it's all right now, Donald Trump says
he wants you to be his running mate.
What do you say?
We've had this conversation.
I said, if the royal family invites you in
and they want you to come in, I said, yes.
You said yes.
Before you know it, I don't think President
Trump needs a vice president.
He's that powerful.
That's a kind of that's a cop out, if I've
ever heard one.
We know Carrie is desperate to be Trump's
VP, desperate.
Desperate to be Trump's V.P..
But that's really something.
Trump is so good, he doesn't even need a vice
president.
Wow.
There's an idea.
If he runs, he's that powerful as a leader.
He doesn't really need one.
But I do hope he picks somebody who the media
fears more than they fear him.
Is that you?
And you know why I think he should do that?
Because then they'll stop trying to take him
down.
All right.
So, I mean, you can get the gist of just how
completely debased and disconnected from reality
Carrie Lake is.
We'll look at one more clip of this.
In this one, Carrie Lake pulls out the Big
Pharma's controlling everything thing.
And this is the context of saying we can't
really talk about the truth of vaccines.
It's an anti-vax rant riddled in an anti-corporate
rash.
Talk about big Pharma, just like you can't
talk about the industrial complex because
they control the media.
You can control me.
You cannot talk about Big Pharma famously.
Nobody controls me.
You do?
No, no, you can't talk about Big Pharma right
now.
You can't talk about how dangerous the vaccines
are.
Well, but that's not true.
You can't talk about anything.
The vaccines were dangerous.
Really?
No.
You're not seeing some of the consequences.
I think the vaccines actually were a remarkably
safe.
Okay, let's talk about something we can probably
agree on.
Yeah, the vaccines were remarkably safe.
I wish they worked better at preventing transmission,
but the vaccines were extraordinarily safe.
And so this is this is a common refrain.
So this you really have to go beyond just
a single sentence and delve into this whole
big pharma control sort of thing.
It is absolutely true that pharmaceutical
companies are large advertisers on TV.
Most countries don't even allow direct to
consumer advertising.
You know, do you feel tired in the morning?
You might be suffering from what?
Right.
They spend a ton of money advertising their
products.
They spend money with pharmaceutical rep.
Like that's all absolutely true.
They are profit driven.
All of those things are absolutely true.
And also the scale of pharmaceutical companies
has led to incredible advances in our ability
to treat.
And in some cases I wish it were more prevent
disease, keep people alive in circumstances
where they previously would have died.
Like that's all all of these things can be
true at the same time.
But there are numerous examples of investigative
journalism, news organizations doing in-depth
investigations into the practices of pharmaceutical
companies.
We've seen what's happened over the last ten
years with reports about opioids and the ways
in which the pharmaceutical companies have
lobbied and pushed for more prescribing, even
though they knew that these were highly addictive.
These things are featured on mainstream news
programs all the time and independent programs
as well.
In 2020, CBC News had this major investigation
about the cost of prescription drugs, and
they actually interviewed pharmaceutical executives,
industry experts, patients who couldn't afford
medications.
NBC News in 2019 had a major series about
the opioid epidemic, and they interviewed
families that were affected.
They did investigations into how pharmaceutical
companies were promoting the use.
2018 ABC had another one about opioid.
There are all of these examples.
So what they want to do is normally they say
let companies do whatever they want.
Don't don't limit them.
Don't regulate them, whatever.
But now that we want to talk about supposedly
dangerous COVID vaccines, which weren't dangerous,
which aren't dangerous.
Now all of a sudden it's you're owned by the
pharmaceuticals and nobody can talk about
it, and it's all but everybody's being silenced.
And whatever the case may be, Kerry Lake is
fundamentally not a serious person.
And my hope is and from all of the data I've
seen, she has a shot at being senator if she
runs.
My hope is that she is soundly defeated in
2024, if indeed she runs for the Senate in
Arizona much more soundly than she was defeated
by a much larger margin than she was defeated
in Arizona in 2022 running for governor.
And quite simply, she lost.
The person who got more votes is now the governor,
and that's the right outcome.